buying a home is one of the dumbest
effing things a human can do with their
money you don't build wealth like that
okay expand you're going to go buy a
house for $500,000 in Las Vegas and
you're going to put down 100 Grand over
there that money could have been put in
yourself just the down payment you could
have invested in yourself in your
business there's not a business or an
individual that can't produce more
Revenue than a single family home the
only thing worse than investing in a
house is giving money to the bank and
letting them have it Bank of America is
going to charge you 8% for 10 years okay
you paid 500 you put a loan on it you
put 8% on $400,000 that's 32,000 a year
times 10 is$ 320 that's your interest on
the first 10 years so you need to sell
your house for 500 plus 320 to break
even what you're saying right now makes
sense to me yeah financially speaking I
don't see the benefit of buying anything
right now interest rates are so high
when I look at the cost of buying versus
renting renting is like half the price
why buy a house right now doesn't make
any sense financially unless you plan to
live there for 30 years